hi ladies and gentlemen greggie here
Carrie here Terry and era the era here
yeah III yeah Hara Erickson is her name
Oh learning remember it get on it she's
on youtube.com slash Tara Erickson
hashtag this idiot hashtag this idiot
why would you say that about yourself
you're not an idiot if you're you're
like right above that my voters your
channel well I sure sketches she's funny
I'm telling you guys she is a sterile
I'll punch you in the face if you doubt
me will beat you up I will beat your ass
like a Cherokee drum stranger things
Mystery Science Theater 3000 riffs you
ready for this let's do some riffin
you've uh you've seen a stranger things
episode of right oh I've seen all of
them I made a YouTube video about it
oh that's how we segue into a video
promotion people set her up I'll use
that thing from fashion
[Music]
Wow Wow awesome
yeah judge truth is stranger than hey I
think this is the prequel to strangest
thing did they make this 10 con wake up
video that's duvet their friends you
know yeah Oh chapter 1 it's a book no
not that I can't read I just prefer not
to write all these titles are like
reverse Star Wars which is a greyish
brownish world of the early ages at
auction 25 to 75 cents I'm sorry little
Timmy is clearly disturbed look how big
the Sun is everyone with milk with an
idiot
this is Ashton copter 9 we're doing a
flyover brasses last meals Lucky's going
to the back screen TV I can't tell the
set decorator bitchin shows for work or
is a genius
haha let me mashed potato sculpture on
the couch are you oh uh you know this
fall doubt right but Edwin has a
haunting me beautiful capsule ah-ha yeah
Linda wasn't me watch this book oh oh
we're just nibble
ah there they are again you know the
Dufferin mothers must be so proud
well even the bird house is a duplex
nice oh dude is this all those jeans
first ah best part of waking up this is
my user yeah got to wash all that fresh
air off can't get unclean French sucks
crap oh not right now
I could have been a clown ah I should
have called it scattered things I've
never been so happy to see someone
finished getting dressed
yeah whoops because to scoop we could
totally binge watch this game man well
do Mystery Science Theater Oh God
it's crazy that they're gonna be doing
something that like yeah I agree
because I remember Mystery Science
Theater for doing like B movies and so
yeah yeah everyone someone I might be
like a pretty popular thing this is like
relevant and current super super current
you think that it's not some old thing
that is so Robin and I'm thinking like
what are they I didn't have a deal with
Netflix where they could do this for
tonight oh stop I mean that would be
amazing like anything on Netflix or any
Netflix original they could probably do
a Mystery Science Theater yeah well who
wouldn't want it I mean if I had a TV
show of you like can you please your
mystery time yeah I wrote it so that you
guys would do the mystery science thing
like I don't even care about this exact
I think they're like the original
reaction channel or reaction people yeah
I agree I mean are scripted a little bit
more it still looks ill they are the
because of you the epitome of listening
to people just watching a video okay
yeah also stranger things I cannot wait
I am in love with stranger things you
see a season 2 trailer no I don't think
so it's out when did it come out your 30
second one or minute one college it is
amazing oh it is amazing you get
spoilers though I don't - I don't I'm
not
watch anything all right maybe I want to
I don't know what the hell's going on
when I watch that tree now you're like
are they on the underside are they above
it are dated to the side what happens
now
how I'm gonna take you to watch that
show I started it I believe it came out
on July 26 if you guys check that date
and you're like you're right then you
know I'm super fan
possibly I remember going in and being
like it was like August being there
already finished it so I don't know a
couple of weeks a couple of weeks is it
okay yeah it took me like three months
really no I was like binge binge binge I
didn't feel that for this actually it
was after episodes three where I felt
that really another episodes I was like
I don't see what the big hype is you but
then after episode three ended was like
that was pretty damn good so that I
started binge watching it yeah so it
took me like two and a half months to
get through the first three episodes oh
man I was all right after that with all
those characters those nerdy very little
kitties with their bicycles and their
eighties clothes you're kidding I love
the 80s did you grow up in Hades yeah I
mean I was born in summer I am an 64
yes born in 1953 she is 67 years old and
I have it or not she works out every day
he was garnier forties for her hair she
does that helps right it helps with age
it helps keep your hair not gray Garnier
protein right yeah I grew up in the 80s
because at that time I was what
30-something I respected something yeah
I would be young and then a woman really
embraces like this was my this is my
hair this is my yeah my time support you
know stranger things is real nostalgic
for this old lady that's all he's going
to so he did he's gonna nod and not say
anything that's what he's gonna do not
gonna clear it up no he's not going to
just click yeah did you watch Mystery
Science Theater I watched it in high
school when we would have detention and
the nice guy when you half the night
science teacher he would let you watch
Mystery Science Theater in detention ah
I didn't watch it on my own it would be
because I was good it would be when I
would go to detention wow that's one
hell of a detention right row the best
I don't know how you got away with it
I'm gonna get that guy fired I know
still works on that hi there he's like
mr. e signs our 1996 here we go again
Netflix yeah I think about these guys
they're gonna dominate everything since
I agreed they have a new studio on
Sunset and Bronson here in LA and oh my
gosh it looks amazing
did you guys know if you drive by their
if their windows turn into light they
can reflect off of them and it turns
into like a huge screen on one world
it's amazing and I have I'd only seen it
lit up like twice but I'm like net legs
you got it all aesthetic getting like
big movie deals now yeah TV shows are
sensational they're picking up TV shows
I agree like black mirror was brought
over here when its third season Mystery
Science Theater is being picked up yeah
like some of the biggest shows on that
place I agree I don't know between
Netflix and like Amazon Prime because
Amazon Prime is the producer on some
dope content right now but so it doesn't
it collects Mentos angry I feel like
hpsp like channels and networks and
whatever streaming gases are better than
a lot of movies out there I agree I told
you yeah I mean comedy they can make
whatever they want they don't have to
deal with executives at the top is know
nothing about comedy or TV or film
they're just like I made it up here
because I went to business
and they're all from the south yeah
about like I went to business and is
this funny it's not no take it away I
don't know what they do up there I'm
just saying Netflix is like yeah I think
this is funny make it
see you later here yeah okay you create
these are like actual creative content
yeah and Mystery Science Theater is not
I feel like out of all channels and
streaming services Netflix is the
perfect place for Mystery Science
Theater to continue living I mean it
pops up right away on my Netflix it's
the first thing that pops up Mystery
Science Theater recommended for you hey
Wow go check out Tara Erickson's channel
on YouTube yeah I'm telling you guys
she's really [ __ ] hell it might like
it you might like it's a big Navy Wow
like she's not funny I don't get it I
feel like so a lot of times I've talked
about your channel and the other videos
yeah I've been really positive I think I
got put it down yeah you bring it bring
it down
yeah you know you don't want to oversell
no no we can't resell it it's like a
stop by the channel if you want before
you click in the video just look at our
channel well just look at it leave it
out if anything yeah anything let's
think do I really care to click a video
it's your face weird is it cool I do I
would I really like this two of them
yeah if you click a video oh don't feel
like you have to watch the whole know
just like the first five seconds and
then get the hell out of there first
impressions are everything and you
really don't want to give anything a
chance to often be very trepidatious
about your experience of going to the
Tara Ericsson chance yeah just just step
lightly
I'm totally likely like just make sure
nobody hears you because if they know
that you're in my channel they're going
to go hey maybe I don't want to hang out
with you anymore
it took me three months to watch all the
stranger things it took me about six -
what finish a video yeah I mean he took
his time and that's why I'm here now I
mean then once he got to be an Evo big
payoff you know he did say that but it
was it was after five minutes of him to
give me a lot of notes on what I could
have fixed but in the end I mean I
suppose you'd lead I mean I I took them
I took the notes take the notes I mean